This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能逍遥法外。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。我们会邀请我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. that you need to.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让一名女子怀上双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. My mind was blown.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次。互联网侦探们费了很大劲才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。我简直惊呆了。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spake, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《你的20岁心理学》，这是一个我们探讨20岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're talking about a relationship style, relationship dynamic that many of you are probably familiar with, either through name or through experience. You may not have the words to describe it. I know when I first heard about it, I didn't, but it's called the Pursuer Distancer Dynamic. If you have ever been in a situation where the moment you feel yourself getting close to somebody or closer to someone, they pull away, or where you're constantly wanting more from somebody, asking somebody to meet your emotional needs, and they just
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要继续剖析20岁的心理。今天，我们要讨论一种你们可能很熟悉的恋爱风格或恋爱动态，无论是通过名字还是亲身经历。你可能没有词汇来描述它。我知道我第一次听说时也不知道，但它被称为“追逐者-疏离者动态”。如果你曾经处于这样一种境地：当你感到自己与某人变得亲近或更亲近时，他们却退缩了；或者你总是想从某人那里得到更多，要求对方满足你的情感需求，而他们却
feel incapable of it, or they tell you that they feel suffocated by you, or or that you are too much that they need space, you have likely experienced this dynamic as a pursuer. Alternatively, if you have ever been in a relationship, been in a situation where you genuinely feel a little bit overwhelmed and you feel like you really need time, you really need space, you really need distance to yourself in a relationship,
感到无能为力，或者他们告诉你，他们感到被你窒息，或者说你“要求太多”，他们需要空间，那么你很可能作为追逐者经历过这种动态。或者，如果你曾经处于一段关系或一种境地中，你确实感到有点不知所措，觉得你真的需要时间，真的需要空间，真的需要在关系中保持距离，
you really feel pressured by somebody, maybe even getting the ick from their affection, even though you really like them, you maybe experienced this dynamic as the distancer. In very, very simple terms, the pursuer distancer dynamic involves one person seeking a deeper connection whilst the other person resists it for whatever reason. And this creates a very frustrating cycle where one person tries to get closer to the other, person to fulfill their own unique emotional needs, which causes the other person to withdraw to protect their needs to compensate for that space then. The pursuer tries harder to get even
你真的感到被某人施压，甚至因为他们的爱意而感到反感，尽管你真的很喜欢他们，那你可能作为疏离者经历过这种动态。简单来说，“追逐者-疏离者动态”涉及一个人寻求更深层的联系，而另一个人出于某种原因抗拒它。这会造成一个非常令人沮丧的循环：一个人试图靠近对方以满足自己的情感需求，这导致另一个人为了保护自己的空间而撤退。随后，追逐者会更加努力地去
closer. The distance that pulls away even further and you kind of see the situation and the cycle that we end up in. And it ultimately continues and ultimately both people end up pretty unhappy and pretty hurt. I've had so many requests for episodes which discuss dynamics like this, especially for people in their 20s who are kind of encountering this for the first time and thinking, like, what's wrong with me? Or like, why can't I get close to somebody? Why don't people love me back? Why do I find love so hard? Nothing is wrong with you. Whichever role you keep falling into, this dynamic is just really complicated. It is formed by so many things we often have, very little control over and very little awareness over from neurobiology to attachment style
靠近。疏离者退得更远，你就能看到我们陷入的这种局面和循环。最终，这会持续下去，导致双方都感到相当不快乐和受伤。我收到了很多关于讨论这类动态的请求，特别是对于那些第一次遇到这种情况并心想“我怎么了？”或者“为什么我不能和某人亲近？为什么人们不爱我？为什么我觉得爱这么难？”的20多岁的人。你没有问题。无论你陷入哪种角色，这种动态都非常复杂。它由许多我们通常无法控制、也几乎没有意识到的因素形成，从神经生物学到依恋类型，
to our nervous system, even to our child psychology. And so that is what we are going to explore today. What is this dynamic? Why do people find themselves in this dynamic? Can you get out of it? Is there something that either person can do to fix a relationship that has fallen into this rut and what does that look like. So that's what we're going to touch on today. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind the pursuer, distancer, relationship dynamic.
再到我们的神经系统，甚至我们的儿童心理学。这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。这种动态是什么？为什么人们会陷入这种动态？你能摆脱它吗？双方是否可以做些什么来修复陷入这种困境的关系？它看起来是什么样的？这就是我们今天要触及的内容。废话不多说，让我们进入“追逐者-疏离者”恋爱动态背后的心理学。
On the surface, the pursuer distancer dynamic, I think seems very intuitive, right? There's generally one person who wants more, one person who wants less. The person who wants more, the pursuer, the person who wants less is the distancer. I feel like we already kind of went through this, but just as a reminder.
从表面上看，追逐者-疏离者动态似乎非常直观，对吧？通常有一个人想要更多，一个人想要更少。想要更多的人是追逐者，想要更少的人是疏离者。我觉得我们已经讨论过这一点了，但作为提醒。
The pursuer typically, It's not that just they want more of everything. What they really want more of is connection and intimacy and reassurance. And they want to fight through their fights. They want to know that everything's okay. They want to know why somebody's angry with them. They want to work it out in the moment. They want to know they're loved.
追逐者通常并不是说他们想要更多的一切。他们真正想要更多的是联系、亲密感和安全感。他们想要在争吵中解决问题。他们想知道一切是否还好。他们想知道为什么对方在生他们的气。他们想在当下解决问题。他们想知道自己是被爱的。
They want more date nights. They want maybe more sex. They don't want enmeshment. They just want very deep intimacy. and that is a core need for them. In contrast, the distance are, it's not that they don't want that. It's just that it's a little bit harder for them. They prefer their alone time.
他们想要更多的约会之夜。他们可能想要更多的性生活。他们不想要纠缠不清。他们只是想要非常深层的亲密感，这对他们来说是一种核心需求。相比之下，疏离者并不是不想要这些。只是这对他们来说有点困难。他们更喜欢独处的时间。
They need their space. They like to process things independently. They value quality time over the quantity of time. They don't like feeling smothered. Sometimes they push the other person away, not because they don't love them, not because they're not interested, but just because it is too much. and that can come off as really, really dismissive. Of course it's going to.
他们需要自己的空间。他们喜欢独立处理事情。他们看重质量胜过数量。他们不喜欢感到被窒息。有时他们把对方推开，不是因为不爱对方，也不是因为不感兴趣，只是因为这太沉重了。这可能会显得非常冷漠。当然会显得如此。
It's going to come off as if this person doesn't want to be with you. It's not always like that, but I think this is like the general profile of each role. That's typically what it would appear like from the outside. It's also worth noting this doesn't just happen in romantic relationships, but in friendships as well. Even sometimes with parents. One friend, for example, really wants more, more of everything. more one-on-one-time, more invitations, more of a connection,
这看起来好像对方不想和你在一起。情况并不总是这样，但我认为这是每个角色的基本特征。从外部看，通常就是这样。值得注意的是，这不仅发生在恋爱关系中，也发生在友谊中。甚至有时与父母之间也会发生。例如，一个朋友真的想要更多，更多的一切：更多的单独相处时间，更多的邀请，更多的联系，
and the other person is maybe fearful of being engulfed by that friendship, fearful of becoming too dependent on that one person, fearful of being hurt. Again, like I said, it may also happen with parenting, where a parent can feel really uneasy by this idea that their whole identity is going to become that of a mom or that of a dad. so they push their child to be independent so that they can be as well. That is a whole other episode. It's a lot less common, maybe more common actually. It's really actually the root of a lot of attachment pain. But yeah, the pursuer distance of dynamic gets a big hype in relationships
而另一个人可能害怕被这种友谊吞噬，害怕变得过于依赖那个人，害怕受到伤害。正如我所说，这也可能发生在亲子关系中，父母可能会因为“自己所有的身份都将变成妈妈或爸爸”这种想法而感到不安，所以他们会推动孩子独立，以便自己也能独立。那是另一集的内容了。这可能没那么常见，或者实际上更常见。这确实是许多依恋痛苦的根源。但没错，追逐者-疏离者动态在恋爱关系中非常受关注，
and when you start looking for you kind of see it everywhere. The thing is, it's not wholly unhealthy, right? In itself, it's not that terrible. Maybe people are going to be mad at me for saying that, but every relationship will have some aspect of distancing and pursuing in it. Dare I say it's healthy to have that chase for both people to occasionally play each role in a fight, to show the other person they care about them, or even when it comes to intimacy, right, to feel needed, to also feel a little bit needy. There have been a lot of relationship therapists who would say that the push and pull on that level keeps a spark alive. However, when A, both people always play the same role all the time,
当你开始关注时，你会发现它无处不在。问题是，它并不完全是不健康的，对吧？它本身并没有那么糟糕。也许人们会因为我这么说而生我的气，但每一段关系都会有某种程度的疏离和追逐。我敢说，双方偶尔在争吵中扮演各自的角色，向对方展示他们在乎对方，甚至在亲密关系中，感到被需要，同时也感到一点点被需要，这其实是健康的。许多关系治疗师会说，这种程度的推拉能保持火花。然而，当A，双方总是扮演同一个角色；
B, both people feel frustrated by the other's reaction, and C, they can't talk about it, they can't see the other person's perspective, they're not willing to change, that is where we have the unhealthy pursuer-distance dynamic. Nobody is happy. And the thing is, is that each person is also constantly triggered by the other person because there is so much like natural friction leading to this impasse. In this situation where one person wants more and one person wants less, I think the real issue is like who should have to compromise? Like who whose way wins? Who has to receive less or more or a different amount of the behavior that they want, that they want? So there was this source at the Gottman Institute.
B，双方都对对方的反应感到沮丧；C，他们无法谈论它，无法理解对方的观点，也不愿意改变，这就是不健康的追逐者-疏离者动态。没有人是快乐的。问题在于，每个人也都在不断地被对方触发，因为这种自然的摩擦导致了僵局。在这种一个人想要更多、一个人想要更少的情况下，我认为真正的问题是：谁应该妥协？谁的方式胜出？谁必须接受比他们想要的更多、更少或不同程度的行为？戈特曼研究所（Gottman Institute）有一个来源，
which is one of the world's biggest research labs on love and dating. And this person basically says that this dynamic is one of the main reasons that couples fall out of love. They researched thousands of couples on this pursue a distance of dynamic. And they discovered that when people get stuck in this dynamic, whether they are, I don't know, 19, 27, 49, whatever it is, they have more than an 80% chance of breaking up or divorcing in the next four to five years. Those aren't good odds. So we really do need to understand what's actually going on below the surface. What's happening in each person's mind?
它是世界上研究爱情和约会最大的实验室之一。这个人基本上说，这种动态是情侣不再相爱的主要原因之一。他们研究了数千对处于这种追逐者-疏离者动态中的情侣。他们发现，当人们陷入这种动态时，无论他们是19岁、27岁、49岁还是其他年龄，他们在未来四到五年内分手或离婚的几率超过80%。这可不是什么好兆头。所以我们确实需要了解表面之下到底发生了什么。每个人的脑子里在想什么？
Let's actually start with the distancer in this dynamic. There is this wonderful man. His name is Augustus Napier. I think that's how you pronounce it. And he is a pioneer in the field of family therapy. He's worked with hundreds of couples on this. In his research, he observed that when someone engages in strong distancing behavior, what they are really motivated by is fear, fear of being engulfed in a relationship, fear of losing a sense of
让我们从这种动态中的疏离者开始。有一位了不起的人，名叫奥古斯都·纳皮尔（Augustus Napier）。我想名字是这么读的。他是家庭治疗领域的先驱。他与数百对情侣合作处理过这个问题。在他的研究中，他观察到，当某人表现出强烈的疏离行为时，他们的动机实际上是恐惧：害怕在关系中被吞噬，害怕失去自我感。
self. And a big part of that is social conditioning. You know, this idea that they don't need anyone. You know, this applies to all genders, but sometimes with men as well, it's because they're scared of being too reliant. They've been taught that they shouldn't be that way. In general, it's this fear of being so attached that if the other person was to leave, if the other person was to disappear, what would they do? Who would they be without that person? That's a strong reason why the distancer is the way they is. You can also just see how much of this comes down to past experience.
其中很大一部分是社会条件反射。你知道，这种“他们不需要任何人”的想法。这适用于所有性别，但有时对于男性来说，是因为他们害怕过于依赖。他们被教导不应该那样。总的来说，这是一种害怕过度依恋的恐惧：如果对方离开，如果对方消失，他们该怎么办？没有那个人，他们会是谁？这就是疏离者之所以如此的一个重要原因。你也可以看出这在多大程度上归结于过去的经历。
Yes, in childhood with parents, as somebody who wanted unconditional love, from a parent, from a caregiver, and realizing that wasn't on offer. realizing that you could only ever rely on yourself, but also from early romantic relationships, even friendships, where at some stage, the distances has thought, this person is amazing, this person is the one, I'll give them everything, I'll show them how invested I am, and it didn't end well. They left. They found a new best friend. They didn't love them back in the same way. and our minds, our bodies hold on to that. They store it in a very deep and dark place.
是的，在童年时期与父母的关系中，作为一个想要从父母或照顾者那里得到无条件爱，却意识到那是不可能的人，你会意识到你只能依靠自己。但也源于早期的恋爱关系，甚至是友谊，在某个阶段，疏离者曾想：“这个人太棒了，这个人就是我的真命天子/女，我会给他们一切，我会向他们展示我投入了多少”，但结果并不好。他们离开了。他们找到了新的好朋友。他们没有以同样的方式爱他们。而我们的思想和身体会紧紧抓住这些。它们把这些记忆储存在一个非常深且黑暗的地方。
And they then change, our body, our mind then changes all of our future behaviors to avoid that ever happening again at all costs. We don't want to live through that hurt. We don't want to be disappointed in somebody else again. And the best way to ensure that is to just hold everyone at arm's length. is just to make sure that there is always something just for you, something they don't know about, a past, a memory, a hobby, a friendship that you can escape into should you feel overwhelmed, should things be going pear-shaped?
然后，我们的身体和思想会改变我们未来所有的行为，以不惜一切代价避免这种情况再次发生。我们不想再经历那种伤害。我们不想再对别人感到失望。确保这一点的最好方法就是把每个人都拒之门外。确保总有一些东西是只属于你自己的，一些他们不知道的事情：一段过去、一段记忆、一个爱好、一段友谊，如果你感到不知所措，如果事情变得糟糕，你可以逃避到那里。
To them, it's safety. It's insurance, but to the pursuer that looks like secrets, it looks like distance, it looks like an unwillingness to try and open up. It may also come down to simply how they learnt to self-reaching. regulate. I think I just mentioned it, but, you know, a big part of being a disinsurer as personal history is that they obviously learned that they needed to take care of their own emotions and their own problems. There is a great deal of overlap here with hyper-independence and emotional avoidance and only needing to rely on themselves. And this isn't always because their parents or their
对他们来说，这是安全感。这是保险，但对追逐者来说，这看起来像是秘密，看起来像是疏离，看起来是不愿意尝试敞开心扉。这也可能归结于他们学习自我调节的方式。我想我刚才提到了，作为疏离者，个人历史的一个重要部分是，他们显然学会了需要照顾自己的情绪和问题。这里与过度独立和情感回避以及只依赖自己有很大的重叠。这并不总是因为他们的父母或家庭疏忽或出了什么问题。只是在他们生命中的某个阶段，他们遇到了压力，遇到了非常沉重的事情，也许不是创伤，只是非常沉重，他们意识到如果他们能自己处理，也许那样更有效。他们不需要被辜负。也许当时没有人在那里可以帮助他们。他们不想成为负担，特别是在男性身上，对吧？强烈的情绪。也许他们曾经有机会表达过一次，但没有得到很好的回应。所以现在，那种方法被排除了。本质上，他们意识到，当坏事发生时，如果他们走开，如果他们自我隔离，如果他们对问题进行足够的理性化，它就会被解决。
family were neglectful or something went wrong. It's simply that at some stage in their life, they've encountered stress, they've encountered something that was very heavy, maybe not traumatic, just very heavy, and they realized that if they could just deal with it themselves, maybe that was more effective. They didn't need to be let down. Maybe there wasn't somebody there available to help them. They didn't want to be a burden, especially, I think, with guys, right? Big emotions. Maybe they did have a chance to express them once, and it wasn't taken well. So now it's that idea, that approaches off the table. Essentially what they realized was that when something bad happens, if they go away and if they self-isolate and if they rationalize a problem enough, it will be
他们不需要依赖别人的帮助。而且也许他们也不必在当时被别人的情感问题所困扰。你知道，只拥有自己感觉自由多了。这就是他们遵循的情感蓝图。这就是他们带着伤口进入的状态。而追逐者带着看起来非常不同的伤口进入，但实际上可能是一样的。同一位研究员纳皮尔在类似的研究中观察到，在观察追逐行为时，这个人通常是由对拒绝的恐惧、对被独自留下的恐惧所驱动的。所以他们寻求频繁、强烈的联系来安抚这种恐惧。对他们来说，他们可能确实经历过与疏离者完全相同的经历：被抛弃、被伤害、感到被忽视，但他们的反应是深入进去，不让彼此之间留下任何距离，不让疏离发生。追逐行为的一部分是情绪监控，对吧？不断地问：“嘿，你还好吗？你在生我的气吗？我们能谈谈吗？到底怎么了？”想要掌握我们关系进展的动态。这可能非常健康。但有时它会达到一种不断寻求保证的地步，不断地需要知道对方每一秒的情绪，这样就不会有被突袭的机会。你如何防止自己被突袭、被抛弃？就是确保每一个情绪在每一刻都是可见的。每一个可能出现的问题，你都在一百公里外就意识到了。这就是为什么追逐者行为的一大部分是：是的，承担关系的情感劳动，进行关系维护，提出问题，因为他们想要与这个人有未来，但也因为也许他们内心的一部分在想：“这样我就能预知如果有什么事情会炸开。”这有时会发展成，是的，再次成为一种强迫症或非常强烈的行为。
solved. And they won't have to rely on somebody else's assistance. And maybe they won't have to be burdened by somebody else's emotional problems at time as well. You know, it just feels a lot more freer that they just have themselves. So that is the emotional blueprint they follow. this is the wound they're entering with. And the pursuer is entering with what seems like a very different wound, but is actually probably the same one. That same researcher, Napier, here observed in similar research that when looking at pursuing behavior, this individual is often motivated by a fear of rejection, a fear of being left alone. So they seek frequent intense connection to soothe that fear. For them, they maybe actually went through some of the very same experiences as the
对于疏离者来说，这本身不是一种强烈的行为，但对于疏离者来说，这是一种强烈的行为，比如：“为什么你总是干涉我的事？为什么你总是对我要求这么多？”并不是这个人或这种情况下的任何人坏了，或者做错了什么。这只是他们对可能受到伤害和社交痛苦的前景所做出的反应。你们中有些人可能会问，如果伤口可能相似，是什么让一个人走上一条路，而另一个人走另一条路？是什么让某人成为疏离者，又是什么让某人成为追逐者？
distancer of being left, of being hurt, of feeling unseen, but their reaction to it has been to go deeper, to not leave any gap between them and the other person for distance to occur. Part of pursuing behavior is emotional monitoring, right? Constantly being like, hey, are you okay? Are you mad at me? Can we talk about that? Like, what's going on? Wanting to keep tabs on how our relationship is going. That's probably very healthy. But then sometimes it getting to a point of like constant reassurance seeking, constantly needing to know every second of the other person's emotions so that there is no opportunity to be blindsided. How do you prevent yourself from being blindsided from being left is making sure that every single emotion is visible at every
同样，是的，一部分归结于过去的经历，一部分归结于社会化。我觉得我们可以说更多的男性可能比女性更容易成为疏离者，并不是说这是排他的，但主要还是神经系统的调节问题。从调节的角度来看，这些模式通常映射到不同的压力反应。疏离者通常倾向于一种“去激活”策略。所以当压力上升时，他们的神经系统会说：降低强度，退后，独自自我安抚。
single time. Every single issue that could come up, like you were aware of it, a hundred kilometers down the road. That's why a big part of pursuers' behavior is yes. Doing the emotional labor of the relationship, doing the relationship maintenance, bringing up problems because they want a future with this person, but also because maybe a part of them is like, this way I kind of get inside it into if something's going to blow up in my face. And that can sometimes develop into, yeah, again, a compulsion or a very intense behavior
而追逐者倾向于我们所说的“过度激活”策略。所以当压力上升时，他们的系统会说：亲自动手，增加亲密度，寻求保证，解决问题。缩小你和对方之间的距离差距。同样，双方都在试图管理同样的潜在恐惧。我不想再感受到最初的那个伤口。我不想再受到伤害。他们只是以不同的方式这样做，当这两个人找到彼此后，实际上让双方的情况变得更糟。卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）的作品中有一个著名的概念，即“容器与被容纳者”。本质上他说的是，当你观察任何人时，我们都会稍微倾向于这两种风格或系统中的一种。
for the distancer, not an intense behavior on itself, but an intense behavior for the distancer of like, why are you always in my business? Why do you always want so much from me? And it's not that this person or any person in the situation is broken or has done anything wrong. It's just how they are responding to the prospect of being hurt. and to the prospect of social pain. Some of you may be asking, if the wound is maybe similar, what makes one person go one way and somebody go the other? What makes somebody a distancer and somebody makes somebody a pursuer?
你是那个在自我内部找到情感安全感的“容器”或疏离者，还是那个在关系中找到安全感的“被容纳者”或追逐者？我认为通过这一点，我们可以更清楚地看到这里正在进行的舞蹈。进一步，退一步。实际上，双方总是在以相反的方向同步移动，从未触碰，对一个人来说从未足够亲近，对另一个人来说又太亲近。所以我们现在可能都在问的问题，我知道我肯定问过，是为什么人们会留下来？为什么这两种人经常找到彼此？如果从我们的角度来看，看起来他们就不应该
Again, yeah, a bit of it comes down to past experiences, a bit of it comes down to socialization. I feel like we could say a lot more men are probably going to be distances than women, not that it's an exclusive thing, but majorly it's nervous system regulation yet again. From a regulation standpoint, these patterns often map onto different stress responses. Distances often lean towards a deactivating strategy. So when stress rises, their nervous system says, like, reduce intensity, pull back, self-soothe alone,
在一起。为什么这种关系动态如此普遍？嗯，这就是我们在短暂休息后要揭示的内容。请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，
and pursuers lean towards what we call a hyper-activating strategy. So when stress rises, their system says, get your hands dirty, increase proximity, seek reassurance, problem self here. Close the distance gap between you and the other person. Again, both people are trying to manage the same underlying fear. I don't want to feel that original wound again. I don't want to be hurt again. They're just doing it in a different way that when these two people find each other actually makes it worse for both people. There is this famous idea in like Carl Jung's work of like the container and the contained. And essentially what he says is that When you look at anybody, we're all going to lean slightly towards one of these two styles or systems.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家交流，并深入探讨那些不切实际且过于复杂的、主导健康产业的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。
Are you going to be the container or the distancer who finds emotional security within the self, or the contained, the pursuer, who finds security in the relationship? And I think with this, we can more clearly see the dance that's going on here. One step in, one step back. Actually, both people are always moving kind of in synchronicity just in opposite directions. never touching, never close enough for one person, too close for the other. So the question we may all be asking at this point, I know I've certainly asked this, is why do people stay? And why do these two kinds of people find each other so often? If from our point of view, it looks like they just shouldn't
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和莉尔·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。
work out. Why is this relationship dynamic so common? Well, that is what we are going to reveal after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter,
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看到
and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex
有一条贯穿线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。所以，谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为对于黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
pseudoscience that doesn't dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对于黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see
我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really?
那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。
Yeah for me It's one of the most important years For black people In American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次。互联网侦探们费了很大劲才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈指控被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。我感觉自己被卡车撞了。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的惩罚。请收听《The Girlfriends》。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。需要知道的关键是，这段关系中的任何一方都没有错。没有人是问题所在。没有人是坏人。我认为疏离者被贴上了“受损者”的坏标签。但那不是真的。双方都有伤口，就像我们所有人一样，我们都带着包袱进入一段关系，我们把它们扔在地板上，我们必须弄清楚哪些物品是我们的，哪些是对方的。问题是，如果一个疏离者和另一个疏离者约会，那可能会很好。如果一个追逐者和另一个追逐者约会，那可能会一帆风顺。这并不是说这些关系不会有问题，但问题不在于个人，
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
而在于由此产生的摩擦。疏离者和追逐者经常找到彼此，是因为对方带来的挑战，也因为这种想要融入彼此生活的渴望。他们都想要一点对方拥有的东西：疏离者想要真正亲近某人的能力，而追逐者想要变得更神秘、更难以捉摸的能力。这令人陶醉。这就像这种阴阳局面，他们都在寻求某种
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
他们所不具备的东西。另一件事是，在追逐-疏离周期的不同时间，每个人都会短暂地得到他们想要的。这就是令人陶醉的地方。在整个周期的某个阶段，对吧，追逐者会变得非常沮丧，他们会完全退缩。他们会回归到冷暴力。他们会使用他们还没想到要使用的工具。他们会
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
精疲力竭。他们会想：“好吧，我要走了。我会给你所有的空间。”在这样做时，他们实际上给了疏离者他们想要的。疏离者终于感到足够冷静、足够调节、能够处理事情了，所以他们回来了。讽刺的是，现在追逐者得到了他们想要的。就像：“怎么回事？这个人终于又在这里了。亲密感回来了。修复和治愈的机会就在这里。”问题是，这看起来像是向前迈进。这看起来像是治愈。这看起来像是你发现了让疏离者靠近的秘密，而疏离者发现了让追逐者走得更远的秘密。这实际上只是同一个
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The key thing to know, neither person in this relationship is wrong. Nobody is the problem. Nobody is the bad guy. I think distances get a bad rap as like the damaged one. But that's not true. Both people have wounds the same way that we all have, we all have baggage that we bring into a relationship and we throw all over the floor and we have to figure out which items are ours and which items are the other persons. The thing is, if a distance are dated, another distance, it would probably be okay. And if a pursuer dated another pursuer, it would probably be smooth the sailing. It's not to say those relationships aren't going to have issues, but it's not the individuals
绝望模式的新形式。当这种情况发生时，双方会非常短暂地交换角色，对吧，在很短的时间内。这使得作为追逐者或疏离者的自我认同变得更加困难和令人困惑，因为如果双方有时——在非常短的时间内——扮演对方的角色，那肯定不是问题，但相反的角色并不自然。同样，这是暂时的，这是一个小的转换，这是循环持续的症状。双方都变得如此激动，以至于他们短暂地变成了对方。那么这里发生的长期损害是什么？这些关系通常是如何结束的？治疗师谈论这一点
that are the problem. It's the friction that has caused. Distances and pursuers find each other a lot because of the challenge the other person presents, but also because of this desire to kind of fit into each other's lives. They kind of both want a little bit of what the other person has. the ability to get truly close to somebody for the distancer and the ability to be a little bit more mysterious and elusive for the pursuer. It's intoxicating. It's like this yin and yang situation where they both are kind of seeking something that
在这样的关系中，那个一直寻求情感、想要亲密、促使那些深度对话的人，他们变得沉默了。他们变成了我们所说的“精疲力竭的追逐者”。他们基本上完全停止了反应。同样，正如我们所描述的，这种“我的手举在空中，我不知道该怎么办，我不知道如何让你靠近我，所以我打算放弃”的情况。是的，治疗师谈论这个时刻，他们说：“这就是我感到害怕的时候。这就是看起来关系可能要彻底破裂的时候。”问题是，它看起来可能是一次性发生的，但如果你是追逐者，
they're not. The other thing is that at different times during the pursuit distance cycle, each person is briefly going to get what they want. And that is the intoxicating thing. At some stage, right, in this whole cycle, the pursuer is going to get really up. upset and they're going to pull all the way back. And they're going to revert to the silent treatment. They're going to use tools they haven't thought to use yet. They're going to be
你可能已经跑了很长时间的这场比赛了。同样的循环已经进行了很多轮：退缩，他们向前迈进，有暂时的亲密，一切看起来都很棒、很乐观，然后事情慢慢回到原来的样子。你可能已经有很多次想：“我想要的只是你告诉我你爱我。我想要的只是你和我一起解决问题。我想要的只是你记住小事，想要修复我们关系中的问题。”而情感负担变得太重了。然后，当它达到这一点时，就没有回头路了。
exhausted. They're going to be like, fine, I'm going to go. I'm going to give you all the distance. And in doing this, they actually give the distance to exactly what they want. And the distance to finally feels calm enough, regulated enough, able to process things enough, so they come back. And ironically, now the pursuer gets what they want. It's like, how? finally this person is here again. The intimacy is back. The chance to repair and heal is here. And the thing is is that this looks like forward movement. It looks like healing. It looks like you've discovered the secret to getting the distance are closer and the distance discovered the secret to getting the pursuer to move further away. It is literally just the same
另一个人牺牲自己的需求太久了。疏离者也可能有这样的时刻，他们感到太累了，因为试图为对方改变而感到太不自然，以至于他们直接跳船了。他们恐慌了。他们不仅仅变成了疏离者，他们变成了逃跑者。他们再也做不到了。这种不匹配变得太明显了。人们留下了伤痕，留下了沮丧和悲伤。
desperate pattern in a new form. When this happens, very briefly, both people switch roles, right, for a short period of time. this makes self-identification as the pursuer or distancer really a lot harder and very confusing because if both people are at sometimes like very small amounts of times playing the other role surely we're surely it's not an issue but the opposite role doesn't come naturally again this is temporary this is a small switch this is a symptom of the cycle continuing both people get so worked up that they briefly become the other person. So what is the long-term damage happening here? And how do these relationships often end? Therapists talk about this point
一种新形式的绝望模式。当这种情况发生时，两人会在很短的时间内互换角色。这使得人们很难界定自己是追求者还是疏远者，而且会让人感到非常困惑，因为如果双方在某些极短的时间里扮演了对方的角色，这当然不是问题，但这种反向角色并不会自然而然地持续下去。这只是暂时的，是一个小小的转换，是循环持续的一种症状，双方都变得如此激动，以至于他们短暂地变成了对方。那么，这里造成的长期损害是什么？这些关系通常是如何结束的？治疗师们谈到了这一点
in a relationship like this where the person who has always been the emotional seeker, the one who wants closeness, who spurs on those deep conversations, they just become silent. They become what we call a burnt-out pursuer. They basically just stop reacting altogether. again, as we were describing, this situation of just like, my hands are up in the air, I don't know what to do, I don't know how to get you closer to me, so I'm just going to give up. And yeah, therapists talk about this moment, and they say, like, this is when I get scared. This is when it looks like the relationship is probably going to break apart for good. And the thing is, is that it may look like it comes all at once, but if you are the pursuer,
在这样一段关系中，那个一直以来寻求情感、渴望亲密、推动深度对话的人，突然变得沉默了。他们变成了我们所说的“精疲力竭的追求者”。他们基本上停止了所有的反应。正如我们所描述的，这种情况就像是“我举手投降了，我不知道该怎么办，我不知道如何让你靠近我，所以我打算放弃了”。是的，治疗师们谈到这一刻时会说，这让我感到害怕。这就是关系看起来可能彻底破裂的时候。问题在于，这看起来像是突然发生的，但如果你是那个追求者，
you've probably been running this race for a long time. There have been so many rounds of the same cycle of pulling back, them stepping forward, there's a temporary closeness, it all looks great, optimistic, and then things slowly return to the way they are. You have probably had so many times of being like, all I want is for you to say that you love me. All I want is for you to say is to work on a problem with me. All I want is for you to remember the small things, to want to fix things in our relationship. And the emotional load just becomes too heavy. And then again, when it gets to this point, there is no coming back.
你可能已经在这场竞赛中奔跑了很久。同样的循环已经上演了无数轮：你退缩，他们前进，然后有短暂的亲密，一切看起来都很美好、乐观，但随后事情又慢慢回到了原样。你可能经历过无数次这样的时刻，心想：我想要的只是你说你爱我。我想要的只是你和我一起解决问题。我想要的只是你记住那些小事，想要修复我们的关系。而情感负担变得太沉重了。当达到这一点时，就再也回不去了。
this other person has sacrificed their needs for too long. The distancer might also have a moment like this where they just feel so tired, so unnatural by trying to change for this other person that they just jump ship. They panic. They don't just become the distance or they become the flea. They just can't do it anymore. The mismatch becomes too evident. And people are left hurt, people are left frustrated and sad
另一个人已经牺牲自己的需求太久了。疏远者也可能会有这样的时刻，他们因为试图为对方改变而感到如此疲惫、如此不自然，以至于他们直接放弃了。他们惊慌失措。他们不仅仅是疏远，而是变成了逃跑者。他们再也无法坚持下去了。这种不匹配变得过于明显。人们最终感到受伤、沮丧和悲伤。
in that they gave so many months or years trying to compromise. and you might look at that and think, what did they expect? And the thing is, though, this isn't the only outcome. You might think this is always going to be how pursue a distance and relationships, how the course goes, but there is actually things that people can do to break out of this. That's the good news in this. This is the worst case scenario, but our brain's malleable, their neuroplastic, even into old age, given the right conditions, if you were in this situation right now,
因为他们花了这么多月甚至几年的时间试图妥协。你可能会看着这些，心想，他们到底在期待什么？但事实是，这并不是唯一的结局。你可能认为追求者与疏离者的关系总是这样，过程总是如此，但实际上人们是可以打破这种循环的。这就是其中的好消息。这是最坏的情况，但我们的大脑具有可塑性，是神经可塑的，即使到了老年，在适当的条件下，如果你现在正处于这种境地，
you can adapt your brain to form new synaptic connections, to replace old relationship patterns with healthy ones, to find a new way of bonding and caring and being with somebody else if you want to change. Even if you recognize yourself in what we are speaking about today, there's nothing to say that it is all doom and gloom. Because the core thing here is, if you can relate, you are self-aware. You can see the cycle taking place. And if your partner can also see the cycle taking place as well, your chances are so much better. That self-awareness is like the most critical thing I think I've learned from, you know, so many years of just reading the research. But it does take a lot of compromise from both people to mend and to bring, like both
你可以调整你的大脑，形成新的突触连接，用健康的模式取代旧的关系模式，如果你想改变，就能找到一种新的方式来建立联系、关怀和与他人相处。即使你在我们今天谈论的内容中看到了自己的影子，也没有什么理由说一切都注定是灰暗的。因为这里的核心在于，如果你能产生共鸣，说明你是有自我意识的。你能看到这个循环正在发生。如果你的伴侣也能看到这个循环正在发生，你们的机会就会大得多。我认为这种自我意识是我多年来阅读研究成果所学到的最关键的东西。但这确实需要双方做出大量的妥协来修复和维持，就像双方
people have to want to be at the table. And I think the hard thing is that sometimes the distance it doesn't want to be. They want things to be okay between each other, but the emotional debt of having to try is just too much for them. So if you do want to work through this, you really just have to start with self-compassion. If you're trapped in this cycle, being angry of self, being frustrated, being like, what do I expect? Like, this is never going to work out. Isn't going to help you. You need to allow yourself space to feel composed, to feel clear about what you want, and to be able to regulate your nervous system again, not in the way that you have been doing, which is to either seek an artificial level of closeness or seek an artificial level of distance.
都必须愿意坐在谈判桌前。我认为困难之处在于，有时疏离者并不想这样做。他们希望彼此之间相安无事，但为了尝试而付出的情感代价对他们来说太大了。所以，如果你确实想解决这个问题，你真的必须从自我同情开始。如果你被困在这个循环中，对自己感到愤怒，感到沮丧，心想“我到底在期待什么？这永远不会有结果”，这并不能帮助你。你需要给自己留出空间去感受平静，去清楚自己想要什么，并能够再次调节你的神经系统，而不是像你过去那样，要么寻求一种人为的亲密，要么寻求一种人为的疏离。
Perhaps you are in the cycle because of the reasons that we've spoken about because of psychological childhood wounds. Acknowledge this, give yourself grace, and really ask yourself, you know, if I had a choice, I probably wouldn't choose this. That means that it's probably not my fault. that doesn't give you an excuse to then treat somebody in a way that doesn't feel kind or to be like, or to keep hurting yourself even, but it may also, and definitely will just give you some kindness and provide an explanation for why you are the way you are instead of just because I'm a bad person
也许你陷入这个循环是因为我们谈到的那些原因，因为童年的心理创伤。承认这一点，善待自己，真正问问自己：“如果我有选择，我可能不会选择这样。”这意味着这可能不是我的错。但这并不给你一个借口去以一种不友善的方式对待别人，或者继续伤害你自己，但这可能，也绝对会给你一些善意，并为你为什么会变成现在这样提供一个解释，而不是仅仅因为“我是一个糟糕的人”
or because I don't deserve love. Secondly, you need to have that compassion for the other person. You need to realize that the same way you have wounds, they have wounds as well. It's just that they are acting out their own subconscious unconscious processes in a different way. They are looking for the intimacy that they lack in a different way, just different to you. You are both trying to feel whole again through this relationship and to feel loved. And equally, you're hurting each other, but that's not the way it has to be. Basically, like, you need to step into their shoes and be like, essentially, why would I be the way that I am? Let's swap positions here.
或者“我不配得到爱”。其次，你需要对另一个人有同样的同情心。你需要意识到，正如你有创伤一样，他们也有创伤。只是他们以不同的方式表现出他们潜意识里的过程。他们正在以一种不同的方式寻找他们所缺乏的亲密感，只是方式和你不同。你们都在试图通过这段关系让自己再次感到完整，感到被爱。同样，你们在互相伤害，但这并不是必须如此。基本上，你需要站在他们的角度，问自己：“本质上，我为什么会变成现在这样？”让我们交换一下位置。
Why would I continue a cycle like this? Why would I always put distance? Why would I always need more closeness? Can you have empathy for the other person's position? If you can, I think that's like amazing progress. I think then each person needs to integrate the part they're struggling with, and they need to be committed to change. Here is the hurdle.
为什么我会继续这样的循环？为什么我总是制造距离？为什么我总是需要更多的亲密感？你能对对方的处境产生共鸣吗？如果你能，我认为这就是了不起的进步。我认为接下来每个人都需要整合自己正在挣扎的部分，并且他们需要致力于改变。这就是障碍所在。
Here is the deal breaker. Especially if you are a pursuer right now, listen up. you're the only one putting an effort here, if they just keep making excuses, this isn't about being a pursuer, this isn't about being a distancer, this is about respect. And at this point, it's about whether or not they care about you. Obviously, labeling our behavior matters, but when it becomes a shield of like, well, you know, I just didn't reply to your message for three days because I'm a distancer. I forgot your birthday because I'm a distancer. Or alternatively, like, no, I went through your phone because I'm a pursuer. That's not about labels. It's about respect and it's not
这就是决定性因素。特别是如果你现在是一个追求者，听好了。如果你是唯一一个在努力的人，而他们却不断找借口，这就不再是关于追求者或疏离者的问题了，这是关于尊重的问题。在这一点上，这关乎他们是否在乎你。显然，给我们的行为贴标签很重要，但当它成为一种盾牌时，比如“嗯，你知道，我三天没回你消息是因为我是个疏离者。我忘了你的生日是因为我是个疏离者。”或者相反，“不，我翻了你的手机是因为我是个追求者。”这不是关于标签的问题。这是关于尊重，而且这
respect and it's not healthy and it's not about empathy for the other person or for ourselves. It's an excuse. Be honest. With yourself and with the other person and altogether, are you guys capable of change? Is this person you are with capable of change that they've given any evidence for it? And are they showing you movement that isn't just the same cycle? or are they showing shortcuts? For the anxious person, you need to genuinely learn to self-sooved. You need to learn that you are actually super capable
是不尊重，是不健康的，也不是关于对他人的同情或对我们自己的同情。这只是借口。对自己和对另一个人诚实一点，你们到底是否有能力改变？你身边的这个人有改变的能力吗？他们有没有表现出任何改变的迹象？他们是在向你展示不是同一个循环的进展吗？还是他们在走捷径？对于焦虑型的人，你需要真正学会自我安抚。你需要学会你其实非常有能力
of taking a beat, of taking care of yourself, of reassurance, of seeking safety inside of you. And for the avoidant, I think there needs to be this like test period, this period of like, I'm just going to see how I,
停下来，照顾好自己，给自己安慰，在内心寻求安全感。而对于回避型的人，我认为需要有一个测试期，一个“我只是想看看我……”的时期。
what happens when I take the risk and I talk about my problems. I've never done it before or it's ended badly before. If I'm going to lose this person, what else do I have to risk? I'm going to try. I'm going to tell them I had a terrible day at work. I'm going to tell them that I'm struggling mentally. I'm just going to test how it would feel to be open about that.
当我冒险谈论我的问题时会发生什么。我以前从未这样做过，或者以前的结果很糟糕。如果我要失去这个人，我还有什么可冒险的？我要试一试。我要告诉他们我在工作中度过了糟糕的一天。我要告诉他们我在精神上很挣扎。我只是想测试一下坦诚面对这些感觉会如何。
And I'm going to trust as much as I can in my whole body, I'm going to trust that this person isn't going to let me down. And it's going to hold me emotionally in a way that I probably have always wanted to be held. Both of you then need to do the hardest thing in situations like this, which is realize that you could get hurt. That is a possibility here.
我会尽可能地用我的全身心去信任，我相信这个人不会让我失望。他会以我可能一直渴望的方式在情感上支持我。然后你们两个都需要做在这种情况下最困难的事情，那就是意识到你可能会受伤。这是一种可能性。
Throughout this whole thing, actually, this is the most important thing to realize. I think especially in your 20s, you know, sometimes the best relationships are those that could crush you the deepest because you care about them so much. You know that feeling when you look at somebody and you're like, I really hope you don't hurt me, but this could really hurt me. I think you kind of owe it to yourself to bed on that relationship.
在整个过程中，实际上，这是最重要的一点。我认为特别是在你20多岁的时候，你知道，有时最好的关系是那些最能摧毁你的关系，因为你非常在乎他们。你知道那种感觉吗？当你看着某人，心想：“我真的希望你不要伤害我，但这真的可能会伤害我。”我认为你欠自己一个去赌这段关系的机会。
Because even if it doesn't work out, at least you felt how deeply you could go. Even if people make mistakes, at least you experience true repair. At least you could kind of see how much love you truly have to give. I can totally understand if you don't agree with this. But I think so often we use playing it safe as an excuse to actually be avoidant. You could get hurt here. No amount of protective mechanisms or behavior. behaviors, no amount of withdrawing or moving closer is going to stop somebody from breaking your
因为即使它没有成功，至少你感受到了你能走多深。即使人们犯了错，至少你经历了真正的修复。至少你可以看到你真正有多少爱可以给予。我完全理解如果你不同意这一点。但我认为我们经常把“求稳”当作回避的借口。你在这里可能会受伤。没有任何保护机制或行为，没有任何撤退或靠近的行为能阻止某人打破你的
heart if the relationship wasn't going to work in the first place. But continuing to adopt those behaviours, thinking they're going to protect you, thinking they're going to save you, is most certainly going to break your heart more because it's going to rule out all of these people who could have given you so many amazing experiences and could have given you so much. So when you look at the other person across from you and you acknowledge this could really hurt me, is this the person that you'd be willing to do that for? That's just like the question you have to get to the point of answering at the end of the day. And then you have to trust that they won't. You have to trust that if you put in the steps to be different, they will also do that. If you give somebody space,
心，如果这段关系本身就不会成功的话。但继续采取这些行为，认为它们会保护你，认为它们会拯救你，肯定会让你更伤心，因为它会排除掉所有那些本可以给你带来如此多美妙体验和给予你如此多的人。所以，当你看着对面的人，承认“这真的可能会伤害我”，这是你愿意为之冒险的人吗？这就是你最终必须回答的问题。然后你必须相信他们不会伤害你。你必须相信，如果你采取步骤去改变，他们也会这样做。如果你给某人空间，
if you ask somebody to come in further, they are going to be committed to it and the outcome for both of you is worth it. Because people do change out of this. People do find wonderful, healthy marriages and long-time relationships having come into love and having come into dating with this dynamic. Okay, we are going to take one final tiny break here before we discuss. I think the final big question of the day, I don't know if you guys are asking this, but it's definitely one that me and my friends have spoken about, which is, is it worth it your 20s. Is this kind of relationship and the commitment that you need for this kind of relationship something that you should be doing during this decade?
如果你要求某人进一步靠近，他们会致力于此，而对你们双方来说，结果都是值得的。因为人们确实会因此而改变。人们确实找到了美妙、健康的婚姻和长期的关系，尽管他们带着这种动力进入了爱情和约会。好了，在讨论今天最后一个大问题之前，我们要进行最后一次短暂的休息。我不知道你们是否在问这个问题，但这绝对是我和我的朋友们讨论过的一个问题，那就是：20多岁时这样做值得吗？这种关系以及这种关系所需的承诺，是你在这个十年里应该做的事情吗？
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行交流，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什和莉尔·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都可以谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。然后你完成了那句话。是的。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要。你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's.
我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，在某人的……
Correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess. with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
第二条，永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserved. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
警察似乎不在乎，所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
As I said, a controversial question to finish us off for today, a question I don't actually know the answer to, but I thought it could stir up some thoughts. Is this dynamic worth it in your 20s, especially maybe in your early 20s? What I kind of mean by this question is, and what I mean by this dilemma is that when you're in your early 20s when you're in your 20s, there is this narrative that the world is full of opportunities for love. The world is wide. The world is open to you. There are so many fish in the sea. Should you be spending time in relationships that ask you to change and to do so much for the other person? Is it worth working through this with somebody or should you cut your losses
正如我所说，今天以一个有争议的问题结束，一个我实际上不知道答案的问题，但我认为它可以激发一些思考。这种动态在20多岁时值得吗，特别是在20岁出头的时候？我这个问题的意思是，以及我所指的困境是，当你20岁出头时，有一种叙事认为世界充满了爱的机会。世界很广阔。世界向你敞开。海里的鱼多的是。你应该花时间在那些要求你改变并为对方做很多事情的关系上吗？值得和某人一起解决这个问题，还是应该及时止损
and find a distancer? Find a pursuer who more matches your style. What I think is that sometimes we confuse discomfort in a relationship with pure misalignment. Relationships are always going to have their problem. Maybe this is just your problem. The pursuer distance the dynamic is uncomfortable. It activates you. It brings up old wounds. It exposes your attachment system in ways that feel almost embarrassing.
去找一个疏离者？找一个更符合你风格的追求者？我认为有时我们把关系中的不适与纯粹的不匹配混淆了。关系总是会有问题的。也许这只是你的问题。追求者与疏离者的动态是不舒服的。它会激活你。它会勾起旧伤。它以一种几乎令人尴尬的方式暴露了你的依恋系统。
It's not embarrassing. That's just the way it feels. But discomfort alone isn't the reason or a reason to not try. sometimes discomfort especially in your 20s is data. Personally, I think this decade, it's not just for collecting experiences, it's also for collecting awareness. That is why even if this relationship with the distancer, with the pursuer, doesn't last, it is still worth its weight in lessons.
这并不尴尬。这只是感觉而已。但仅仅因为不适并不是不去尝试的理由。有时不适，特别是在你20多岁时，是数据。个人认为，这十年不仅是为了收集经验，也是为了收集意识。这就是为什么即使这段与疏离者或追求者的关系没有持续下去，它仍然值得它所带来的教训。
If you notice that you consistently choose emotionally unavailable people, that's not random. If you notice that you feel bored when somebody is consistent and is safe, that's not random. If you panic the moment somebody gets close or somebody gets a little bit of space, that is not random. These are patterns that the research shows us will be repeated again and again in life in your 20s until consciously examined. Because patterns don't dissolve just because the person you're in a relationship with changes. What I mean by that is that if you leave every time the pursuer distance or dynamic gets activated, you're probably just going to find yourself in another pursuer. distance a dynamic. You may feel temporarily relieved that you got out of that situation,
如果你注意到你总是选择情感上不可用的人，那不是随机的。如果你注意到当某人始终如一且安全时你感到无聊，那不是随机的。如果你在某人靠近或某人稍微保持一点距离时感到恐慌，那不是随机的。这些是研究表明在20多岁的生活中会反复出现的模式，直到被有意识地审视。因为模式不会仅仅因为你关系中的人改变了就消失。我的意思是，如果你每次追求者与疏离者的动态被激活时就离开，你很可能只是会发现自己陷入了另一个追求者与疏离者的动态中。你可能会因为摆脱了那种情况而感到暂时解脱，
but this is your blueprint. You're going to find a very similar individual attractive very, very soon. The dance just starts with somebody new. That is what so many longitudinal attachment studies have shown us. You know, our internal models for relationships are remarkably stable unless they are actively worked on. And I'm not saying fixed. I'm not saying cured, but brought into awareness. So I think as a pursuer in your 20s, it is worth asking yourself, why am I like this? Why is this showing up in all of my relationships? And is there somebody I feel safe enough to tackle that with?
但这是你的蓝图。你很快就会发现一个非常相似的人很有吸引力。舞蹈只是和新的人重新开始。这就是许多纵向依恋研究向我们展示的内容。你知道，我们内部的关系模型是非常稳定的，除非它们被积极地处理。我不是说修复，不是说治愈，而是带入意识中。所以我认为作为20多岁的追求者，值得问自己：为什么我会这样？为什么这出现在我所有的关系中？有没有人让我觉得足够安全去解决这个问题？
And as a distance, it's worth asking, why does closeness feel so engulfing? Why does needing to be pursued rather than pursuing feel like a connection? Why do I feel attracted when there is uncertainty and when there is certainty I lose interest? Like, this is worth exploring whether the person you explore it with ends up being the one or not. You know, I know people won't agree with that, but I just think your 20s are the safest time to confront this and to really go deep in a relationship like this if the other person is somebody you really care about. because the stakes are emotionally high, yes, but logistically lower. Especially in your early 20s, you might not share children, you might not share mortgages,
作为疏离者，值得问：为什么亲密感让人感到如此窒息？为什么需要被追求而不是追求感觉像是一种联系？为什么当有不确定性时我感到被吸引，而当有确定性时我失去兴趣？这值得探索，无论你与之探索的人最终是否是那个“对的人”。我知道人们不会同意这一点，但我只是认为20多岁是面对这个问题最安全的时期，如果对方是你真正关心的人，那么深入一段这样的关系是值得的。因为风险在情感上很高，是的，但在逻辑上较低。特别是在你20岁出头时，你们可能没有共同的孩子，没有共同的抵押贷款，
definitely don't share decades in decades of shared history and family. So you have flexibility, you have time, you have room to experiment, you have time to repair, working through a dynamic with somebody who is willing to self-reflect is going to be, what I think would be transformative. Again, the relationship might not last forever. There is no promise of that. Remember, we made a promise to each other that we have to be okay with getting hurt, but because you have the opportunity to learn, to learn what it's maybe like,
绝对没有几十年的共同历史和家庭。所以你有灵活性，你有时间，你有实验的空间，你有修复的时间，与一个愿意自我反思的人一起解决这种动态将是，我认为是变革性的。同样，这段关系可能不会永远持续下去。没有那样的承诺。记住，我们向彼此承诺过，我们必须接受可能会受伤，但因为你有机会学习，学习可能是什么样子，
to not always play the same role in a relationship, and to not always be that same hurt individual who enters every relationship looking for something that no matter what the other person cannot give you, because you're either looking in the wrong places or searching for it in people who aren't willing to change. That being said, this is not a blanket endorsement to stay in every relationship that triggers you. There is a difference between a dynamic that is two self-aware people trying to grow and a dynamic that is one person refusing to take responsibility. Sometimes, let's be real, someone isn't a distancer. They just don't like you that much.
而不是在一段关系中总是扮演同一个角色，也不是总是那个进入每段关系都在寻找无论对方如何都无法给予你的东西的受伤个体，因为你要么在错误的地方寻找，要么在那些不愿意改变的人身上寻找。话虽如此，这并不是对每一段触发你的关系都保持下去的全面认可。两个有自我意识的人试图成长与一个人拒绝承担责任的动态之间是有区别的。有时，让我们现实一点，某人不是疏离者。他们只是没那么喜欢你。
It's a hard pill to swallow, but it's true. And trying to label them into wanting to work on their behavior, trying to be like, don't you see? Like, you're a distancer. That's why this isn't working. It's not going to work if they genuinely don't care. Same thing with a pursuer. Sometimes they're not a pursuer.
这是一个很难接受的事实，但它是真的。试图给他们贴上标签让他们想要改变自己的行为，试图说“你没看到吗？你是疏离者。这就是为什么这行不通。”如果他们真的不在乎，这是行不通的。追求者也是一样。有时他们不是追求者。
Sometimes they just genuinely don't have boundaries and don't have respect for you. I think through all this discussion, this is definitely where I want to leave things. be able to identify what is a pattern, what is a wound, and what is just a genuine lack of interest. If someone is dismissive of your emotional bids, if you never get in what you, if you never get out what you give, if you never feel comfortable enough to say, I want to address this, this isn't working, I don't like how this is going, this person isn't it? And again,
有时他们只是真的没有界限，也不尊重你。我认为通过所有这些讨论，这绝对是我想要留下的东西。能够识别什么是模式，什么是创伤，什么是纯粹的缺乏兴趣。如果有人对你的情感需求不屑一顾，如果你付出的永远得不到回报，如果你从来没有感到足够舒服去说“我想解决这个问题，这行不通，我不喜欢事情发展的方向”，这个人就不是那个对的人。而且再次，
it's not about the role you guys play in a relationship. It's not about what you're going. It's not about what dynamic you are falling into, it's just because you guys are not right for each other. And it's just because this other person isn't emotionally safe enough to work through a complicated situation with you. And love is complicated. Relationships are complicated and hard. And half of why they are beautiful, I think, in our 20s beyond, is because somebody else is like, yeah, okay, I'm committed to doing that with you, whatever the outcome. So if they're not it's never going to be as good as you want it to be. And it's definitely your sign to call it quits. So with all of that in mind, a final summary, the Pursue a Distance of Relationship Dynamic,
这与你们在关系中扮演的角色无关。这与你们正在经历什么无关。这与你们陷入什么动态无关，这只是因为你们不适合彼此。这只是因为对方在情感上不够安全，无法与你一起解决复杂的情况。爱情是复杂的。关系是复杂而艰难的。我认为它们在我们20多岁及以后之所以美丽，有一半是因为另一个人说：“是的，好吧，我致力于和你一起做这件事，无论结果如何。”所以如果他们不是，它永远不会像你想要的那样好。这绝对是你分手的信号。所以考虑到所有这些，最后总结一下，追求者与疏离者的关系动态，
unbelievably prevalent, by the way, even over the course of researching this episode, not that I seek all of my examples from my friends and family, but it's definitely apparent in past relationships of mine and in people that I see around me. Once you start noticing it, you cannot stop noticing it. We do all typically fall one way, not completely one way or not to an extreme, but whether we are a pursuer, whether we are a distancer, comes down to attachment, comes down to nervous system regulation amongst a bunch of other things. That doesn't mean you won't find love. It doesn't mean all your relationships are doomed. With the right person, you will grow. You will love each other or find a connection that is,
顺便说一句，令人难以置信地普遍，即使在研究这一集的过程中，并不是说我从我的朋友和家人那里寻找所有的例子，但这绝对在我过去的关系中以及我周围的人中很明显。一旦你开始注意到它，你就无法停止注意到它。我们确实通常都会倾向于某一方面，不是完全倾向于某一方面，也不是达到极端，但无论我们是追求者还是疏离者，都归结为依恋，归结为神经系统调节以及其他许多事情。这并不意味着你不会找到爱。这并不意味着你所有的关系都注定失败。与对的人在一起，你会成长。你们会相爱，或者找到一种联系，
so incredibly deep if the other person is committed to it, even if it takes a while. So that is the message I want to leave on. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, let me know, are you a distancer or are you a pursuer? Or are you somewhere in the middle? Which role do you find yourself relating to more? Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and that you maybe have watched an episode on Netflix if you are listening in the US or Canada. We actually recently got a new studio and it is very, very cool and a real vibe. So if you want to check that out and see behind the scenes of where I'm recording from right now, you can go and watch that over there. We also have a substack. If you want to read
如果对方致力于此，即使需要一段时间，也会变得如此深刻。所以这就是我想留下的信息。如果你已经看到了这里，并且正在Spotify上收听，请告诉我，你是疏离者还是追求者？或者你介于两者之间？你发现自己与哪个角色产生更多共鸣？确保你在Instagram上关注我们@ThatPsychologyPodcast，如果你在美国或加拿大收听，你可能已经看过Netflix上的一集。我们最近实际上有了一个新工作室，它非常非常酷，很有氛围。所以如果你想看看那个，看看我现在录音的幕后，你可以去那里看看。我们还有一个Substack。如果你想阅读
our transcripts instead of listen to them in podcast form. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Thank you for tuning in. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts.
我们的文字稿而不是以播客形式收听它们。但直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。感谢收听。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上搜索“TWO%”。
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逍遥法外。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我明白了。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you give your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的
therapist and host, Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，在销售中，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to LoveTraft podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。